okay ladies ever welcome to the podcast
the third attempt you guys don't go the
behind the scenes hey they don't need to
know how many like watch jobs that we've
had this is the first time give them
trade secret I don't why by taking
everybody behind the curtain like when
you tell a joke that does weld you tell
the audience like that actually bomb 12
times tonight every time I get a chance
to bring him on stage I always say I
love how his brain works and what I love
is like to me that's very flattering
when I'm being brought up because we're
friends and stuff but I always think of
an audience member like that's such the
weirdest credit first if you're just
watching comedy in the crowd cuz like
everybody else the store is like alright
you know from like the Joe Rogan
experience and countless comedy special
and for me you make it sound like I'm a
Mentalist do you like I love the way
this guy's mind works for me please
welcome can I say your name please
welcome mr. Fahim Anwar there you are
yeah i know i you know what's funny is i
always can tell that I've thrown you for
a loop when I bring you up on stage
because you come at you when you walk up
you're like what was that I kind of love
it though cuz it's like a great
icebreaker cuz every I like addressing
that intro and just pretending I'm a
Mentalist and like pick a number like
between 1 and 50 did your dad died three
years ago
whoa I like bringing you up and I like
alright I like going before Brad
Williams also oh why that because I do
like some jokes that set him up
perfectly mm-hmm you know like he always
does it like I'll do the jokes and then
whatever I'm saying he'll go right in
and be like you know everybody's jokes
it's like you know so just work so I
love that but yeah man I am I am a fan
of yours you know I you know it's just
we're friends and we know each other but
I mean I honestly am a fan I like
there's very few comics that I will sit
in the back and watch them do common I'm
the same way and like you're you're that
for me as well I'm a fan
you say that but I'm just but it's true
when we go to when we go like have a
dinner and stuff after the shells and
stuff like or we're in the hallway after
I watch your set like we'll have tags
for each other and true like we're kind
of kindred comedy spirits so like a lot
of your jokes are kind of in my
wheelhouse that's why I'm like oh this
would be good or what about this and
like we kind of get giddy off that you
know yeah there's been a few times to
where I go oh I should have thought of
that you know like how you you walk the
line you know I always talk about that
cuz like the store is like a gym and
I'll see you try to tackle like a
hot-button issue and I'm watching it day
one of you doing it and it's not going
over well you know what I mean like some
of the crowd thinks you're a monster you
know and you would be doing you'd be
killing but you want to get into your
new stuff and now half the crowd thinks
you're a monster and it's off-putting
but I just love it as a comic because I
know this is day one and I can't wait
til when it's finished and I'm just
watching it I'm watching the genesis of
it there are countless bits of yours
where I'm like uh he cracked it right
right right I appreciate that I mean but
the thing is like what I was what I was
not enjoying about the Comedy Store is
it wasn't a gym anymore
do you know when I got passed it was the
dark ages no one was going there it was
all about meltdown you know at the comic
book store like the alt scene was very
it was it was like high-octane running
on all cylinders and no one the store
didn't even exist pretty much but there
was a beauty to it that man I took some
of the biggest swings in my comedy
career because there were no stakes
whatsoever you'd like there's no
industry there you could really
experiment yeah and then all of a sudden
this big shift happened and it turned
into like the hottest place to be and
like all these there's always agents and
directors and all these people they're
going and then they're you're being seen
then you're forced to like you're doing
a Friday night 9:00 p.m. spot every
single night yeah Tuesday like a Tuesday
which is supposed to be kind of like a
warm-up or just like work on some new
stuff you're sandwiched between row
again in like sebastian and and and
everyone like you're not gonna do your
new stuff in that time yeah it was weird
for me because you know because then
like you know like just specifically
it's like there was this club that i'd
played before i hadn't been back in a
while and Bobby Lee told me about this
is that like you know they asked because
I said they haven't had me back and he
said well I found out cuz he went to
that club and he was something about
they were at the Comedy Store one night
and I didn't do well or something like
that or whatever I was talking about and
it was probably one of those nights that
I'm like well he worked us out you know
cuz I honestly don't give a [ __ ] like I
yeah I go like okay this is my time like
I knew that I became a professional
comic when I didn't care if the audience
laughed or not it was just about like a
point of emphasis of like I need to work
on this thing and I'm gonna do this and
if they like it or not great but I'll
understand why they didn't like it and
then I'll work on it for the next time
but I've had so many moments like that
at the Comedy Store like no I was doing
this working on this one bit and then
this couple attacked me outside just
like I can't believe you were talking
about it and I had this long 45 minute
discussion with them just because they
you know they're do these pretentious
liberal [ __ ] also they don't understand
it's a work in progress and when people
fail to understand that when you watch a
comedian a lot of people are naive and
think that this is they're like tada
this is it you know you don't know what
day maybe it's like day 1 of 60 of this
bit kind of getting to where it needs to
be and you saw it in its ugliest form
right like you can't judge it upon that
one day there's there's nuance to it
very nuanced and then you have this kind
of feeling though that started to happen
at the county store of being like well I
guess I got to put on a show every night
and I had to go work out someplace else
no you know what I did though like that
started happening at the Comedy Store
where just everyone had to put on their
a-game you couldn't really work on stuff
I would tell Adam to put me up late in
the night late again you know yeah
because I would that's that's the only
way I would feel comfortable
just cuz I didn't want to ruin the show
like if I have a sweet timeslot like
10:30 or 11:00 there's a you kind of
perform for the timeslot you have in my
mind like that's such a meaty people are
coming out and especially when you're
not famous like I didn't have credits
like you or I'm like less known like
people kind of know who you are
so when I get that timeslot I want to do
that type of show and if I want to try
new ideas I would ask anima be like hey
can you throw me up around 12:30 and
that's when it's very sparse in the
crowd and it's it's chill
and it'll laid-back vibe and then I can
just kind of throw ideas out there that
was there like a pressure that you would
feel or put on yourself like when you
would look at the lineup and be like
okay I'm on the line up and it's like oh
man Marc Maron Joe Rogan I would always
happen you know you put your avails in
on Monday you call in you say when
you're available throughout the week and
then they tell you what your spots are
and there are some people energy-wise
where you're like oh cool okay I can
just not that there it's not like
they're easy to follow it's just like
they're complementary energy wise for
you to go up after um whereas some guys
you're like all right how do I attack
this this is tough to go after this guy
it's why you wanted to put town pass -
it's like it's an energist no MC there's
like every what people don't realize I
guess like if you're not an avid comedy
fan don't know how the store works it's
tag team like every other comedy club
there's an emcee so comic will go up
then the emcee he comes in between each
act and kind of like he's the coffee
beans at a fragrance counter just kind
of reset to the room and then the next
comic goes up at the Comedy Store there
is no emcee it's like I do my set then I
bring you up so there's no emcee so when
you have no emcee it's kind of like
whiplash if you have vastly different
personalities and energies so if you
have a guy who's just like swinging off
the chandelier and straight to a
one-liner guy it's like our audience has
to warm up to it it takes like five
minutes before they know what's up yeah
then you become your own emcee it's like
are you going up there to somebody that
does all crowd work and you have to be
like yes like cuz I would always go
after shoot Kingdom I would always go up
after a Rick Ingram you know like or
like at the Comedy Store or sometimes
for a month or you'll be in these phases
where you're all
after a guy or you're always before a
guy yeah yeah and you kind of like trade
off and and whenever I'd go after Rick
Ingraham it was a bit of like how do I
attack this I could I could never just
like stroll into the store I'd have to
be like all right what I want to open
with what joke is best because he's like
a crowd work guy and like people love
crowd work it's so magical to them so
when you have bits like structured jokes
it seems so like fake after crowd work
so you have to figure out a way to kind
of like weave it in I know that's so
frustrating and we've talked about this
privately just being like you know so
here's this thing that I've crafted and
worked on for months maybe years you
know and presenting it to the crowd and
the thing that they want to hold on to
is like when that drug girl said
something and you said this is my
favorite part of the show you know I
understand that though there's a magic
to it because the everyone in the room
knows that it's this event that just
happened for the people in the room
it wasn't contrived it wasn't written it
there's like a fleeting magic to it
whereas a bit is can be great but you
know that it's been honed whereas like
if something happens and off the top of
the head people put a lot of value into
that for some reason yeah too much value
you know yeah it's like a it's like I
would say it's like candy
and bits are like a meal yeah I totally
agree I totally agree I don't um I know
we keep making reference though we
already talked about this but whatever I
I did a show yesterday for the first
time in like since the quarantine
started you know yeah did this weird
outdoor mat ryf put it on and in like in
like the parking lot of his apartment
building and there was chairs set up
everybody was in their own groups and
masks on and I was standing in the back
of a pickup truck with a [ __ ] mic
system yeah yeah it was a show that
would be a nightmare for yet chorus it
was at 6:00 p.m. start time you know in
the daytime but I it was so cathartic
and it was so I was like oh my god I
can't believe I'm doing a show this is
the greatest thing ever I didn't realize
how much I missed it and I even said to
the crowd I was like you know this is I
was like if I invited you to a show if
there was no quarantine I invited you to
a show like this you would laugh your
ass off thinking like I would never go
to a show like that by here these people
were just like so excited to be out so
it's the hottest show in town and they
don't even know it I know it's just it's
just I didn't realize how much I missed
doing stand-up until I did it so I still
haven't done it I think like March 12th
was the last day that I did it it was
the last day the Comedy Store was open
March 12 was my birthday oh wow sorry
I'm late did hahaha I was out in
Tennessee doing shows and I an end it
was like that night it was like they
were like I don't know what's gonna
happen but I ended up doing that show
and I ended up doing the next day and
then I flew home and then the world shut
down yeah I mean it's just I know it's
just it's and it's amazing that now
we're here and like what it what the
date now we're like July and I know to
myself like this like you know that
terrible phrase the new normal the new
normal like when is the new normal gonna
become normal you know like where it's
like oh man what we even dropped the new
off of it where we just accept it yeah
yeah that's why I was I was in a bit of
a funk like when it first hit I was okay
like I'm already kind of kicked myself
anyways but what was great about
stand-up is I get to see my friends and
that's how it would be social I would do
my spots and and I would I would get to
be a social butterfly and catch up and
let in force myself to interact and you
know I'm not so much like an introvert
where it's debilitating but it's kind of
nice to have that part of your schedule
carved out where you you know you're
gonna see your friends and stuff and
very social not even just friends but
like like-minded individuals yes
comedians are a very special breed we
think in jokes so yeah and and losing
that is it kind of sucks yes it does
suck but even not just just that it's
like you know we lost that then we lost
like your people lost writing jobs and
acting jobs and like you know all these
things and you're just kind of sitting
here like wondering like what am I now
what hold it happened what like what's
what's the future going to look like so
we just like for me I'm just fingers
crossed for this
scientists that they come up with
something a vaccine come on nerds maybe
funny for bullying them into like yeah
into like curing this yeah slamming in
the long sleep when you come over to
vaccine dude come on I want to go to
bars [ __ ] hurry up yeah man it's
great like I just saw an article about a
French bus driver was killed by some
passengers who he said you guys have to
put on your mask who's just doing his
job
and they dragged him off the bus and
they beat him to death geez you know
what I mean so you just like like that
don't you you have to worry about the
disease and idiots you know what I mean
like if the coronavirus won't kill you
some guy who doesn't wanna wear a mask
will beat the [ __ ] out of you you know
what's weird about like what we say
about that like normal like there's
certain patterns of behavior that we had
before like okay so yesterday I was
going to pick up some food for my girl
and I and I get out of my car I forgot
my mask so I got in my car and I walk
back and I had like I felt like I had
some flam or something I don't know my
throat so I just you know did a little
thing and I spit on the ground oh that's
an atomic bomb just a biological bomb
you can do that I looked over and there
was a man and a wife pushing their baby
Carla your baby carriage and on the
sidewalk way away from me and they were
looking at me like I literally [ __ ] in
my hand and rubbed it on their kid's
face so then all they see then all they
see is the is a mushroom cloud and like
the ring they have the stroller and then
just like their face gets blown and I
just thought oh man that's but by the
way you probably shouldn't have done
that
even before but true true once i'm tena
is up like if I hear any throat [ __ ]
you're like what's going on yeah man I
feel like but I think there should be
some there should be some bodily
function etiquette now like a way that
you a way that you sneeze like just
maybe maybe it's like a breastfeeding
booth just
for like flem stuff they just send up
around town you get in there and you
it's like a vacuum - can you go can you
go to a bathroom it's too dangerous the
aerosol element there's a there's a
vacuum tube there'd be like but then
they'll be like you know amends and a
woman's and then like the yeah man like
one thing I did notice is you know all
this identity politics stuff and cancel
culture when the pandemic first hit did
you notice how quiet it was on Twitter
for like a month or two there was none
of that because you realize humans were
able to kind of prioritize like all
right bathroom [ __ ] doesn't really
matter right now when I need toilet
paper or whatever the thing the thought
process was no one was trying to cancel
each other over minor transgressions cuz
they were trying to survive as a species
I know I mean but it's back you know but
it's back yeah that's how you know
that's the new normal is they all right
we can go back to canceling people
through a pandemic I even felt it but
even like when after the after you know
you had the George Floyd incident and
then the reaction to it and then the
black lives matter
really heated up there was a time there
was a point there where I was like oh
man can I post my video game uh podcast
it's coming oh yes can I can i people
know understand what you're saying about
being a comedian because we're also a
business it's it's Wharf because our
business is us so it's it's this blurred
line and you want to promote and create
art and put it out there into the
universe but sometimes tragedies happen
or the world is in a weird state and you
you have to use judgment where you go
okay I guess I'm on ice for a little bit
because it's not appropriate and you
have to do that call like me you might
have like a great sketch or a great
stand-up clip and then something
terrible happens and then you go alright
I have to sit on this for a while yeah
and you have to do this fucked-up thing
where you're like okay has enough time
passes you know
have to like see when that time is where
like am i a monster if I start posting
again yeah right that's is that Kara I
felt but you're right about that even
with our jokes you know you know it's
like if some people didn't some people
didn't do that in certain cases like you
know it's like I have a great Kobe
Bryant joke you know yeah yeah not in
the wake of it you know like you mmm you
got to give it a second you know and and
that requires so much you you realize
people's perception of social norms or
why is widely different yeah so
sometimes it's not that they're a
monster it's just like they they just
have no antennae for it and they did an
air on the side of caution you know what
I mean right right right right right so
you do you feel like that because you
also skirt the line you like to like
really it is and it's interesting I do
like to skirt the line and sometimes I
do worry about kind of like perception
and intent and I had this thought the
other day too is sometimes people get
cancelled on Twitter and different
things and it's just because in like
their core community kind of know who
this person is and what their heart is
right but but the larger percentage of
the world has no idea so it's easy to
just like attack some anonymous
soundbite or whatever right well but you
know but the funny thing you say you say
about that is that context is important
you know so we also have to realize that
like if like we can't assume that people
know it's like I realized that with
doing podcast like you're on a podcast
are you saying things and you're like
you're going you're going you say
whatever you want to say odd cast are
like depositions now yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah I do just have all this recorded
footage just to like get [ __ ] by
ourselves from the past yes and and
society progresses but you know like if
somebody could pull up this in the years
30 25 min not 30 25 but like 20 40 or
something let's say and then I I seem so
outdated and unwelcome by those
standards or maybe they'll look back and
be like oh well maybe we'll look back at
like the
like we look at the puritans you know
like The Scarlet Letter like we'll look
back to that like isn't it weird how
similar it is when you think about The
Scarlet Letter how that Twitter is that
it be it becomes that cuz I felt like
this like I felt the pressure of after
the George Floyd thing I felt the
pressure of light we'll have to post
something like what do I do you know
yeah I put the black oh you know you
know the mean and I was like and I felt
I didn't like it like I didn't know like
yeah right after I was like I shouldn't
have done that but then the thing was
now I can't delete it cuz then that what
am I saying there so I was like all in
my head about it and I was so mad at
myself because of that and I cuz I like
that I hate them afresh wrong yeah what
what like what do you do and then it's
like in a post do you not post are you a
monster if you don't post right are you
virtue signaling if you do is just like
you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you don't if you do damned if
you don't for sure so that definitely
was something that I was feeling and
then it's like all the things that have
gone on you know yeah you know it's like
well you know we had there was like you
know some you know like the big
incidents that have happened in the
comedy community and in recent in recent
times right now again you're forced to
be like hey you have to talk about that
you have to if you don't talk about you
know it's like whatever happens like
it's like what the George Floyd if you
if you're if it's like if you're white
and you don't say black lives matter
Twitter makes you feel like that means
you're a racist
you know I've had this model address it
you're you know it's like no phone Lee
you don't get to dictate how I how I
process this and I don't need to share
it with you Internet yeah yeah I agree
like yeah you should be you shouldn't be
dictated by just something like general
like trolls on the internet or something
saying like hey you should like who are
you you're not a network exec or
whatever like but they want they wanna
they make it out let make it out like
they are so again like you skirt the
line with like a lot of a lot of your
material like for instance I remember
one and one of your jokes that I loved
so much but see you like you say you're
a thoughtful person because you're aware
of like I don't want to offend people
but that doesn't stop you from doing it
it just makes you work harder on it to
make sure
that you put it on yeah yeah oh yeah
that'll happen several times oh oh I'm
saying that you had this great joke
about the I think it was the girl with
Down syndrome who was modeling well you
know what's interesting too is sometimes
you'll have jokes and you do them for a
while and society evolves while you're
doing the jokes so it works maybe it
worked maybe three years ago but that's
like one of the jokes that I would I
would not do today you know what I mean
what you're saying I have a couple jokes
where people love them back in the day
but like nowadays it just seems like not
appropriate then you know what I mean
yeah or you have to change you you have
to update it or you changed it or
alcohol I've evolved as a writer and as
a person you know so that's interesting
sometimes we're like a joke stops
working and the crowds is sort of like
you shouldn't talk wait a minute I was
two weeks ago you guys were yes was
killing you know you know it's crazy
hold on I have this um you know you know
George Floyd is happening all the stuff
but but I had this bit from like a year
ago a year or two ago talking about cops
and stuff like kind of addressing police
brutality and this bit would always kind
of sometimes it would smash sometimes it
would put the brakes on the show it
would there's like a lot of tension in
the room whenever I would say it so the
bit I'd be like oh I got in trouble over
a tweet recently like I wrote why go to
West world to kill people with no
consequence when you could just be a cop
and get paid for it
yeah right and then and this is before
all this stuff you know I mean there
were cases but it wasn't so clear-cut
like today and I'd be like you know the
worst thing is nothing happens to these
guys they just get suspended with pay I
go it's almost like these guys are just
planning trips and then realizing they
don't have enough vacation days
he's like Johnson this is the fourth
unarmed black guy you've killed this
month I'm gonna have to suspend you with
pay and then he's just standing there
with a fishing pole like well Sarge you
gotta do what you gotta do who you're
tough but fair you know
it was just such a tense joke where some
people were like they loved it and some
people were kind of like you can't talk
about that and then I posted it recently
after the George Floyd stuff and
unanimously everyone is just like in
favor of it like yes it's getting so
many shares and all that when I remember
a time when it wasn't like that yeah man
I noticed one thing I like about what
you do and by the way for the people
watching if you might not know Fahim but
he had a special
unfortunately he was on seeso but it's
on YouTube now I leveled out David he
leveled up from Saudi yeah yeah which is
this it's polish because like they paid
for it so it looks beautiful it's like a
really well shot special at a theater
and everything and then you know it
bounces around from place to place and
now it's on YouTube and I like that
people can see it yeah there's no
business like show business yeah so chip
makes you check that out check out and
he will also but even a bigger thing
bigger deal even if it might not have
been like widely watched like we like it
should have been but you know theme was
the head writer star of goat-face
on Comedy Central and what was great
about it and groundbreaking about it it
was like you know a bunch of brown guys
from the Middle East in a sketch show
and yeah was it like was that a dream
come true or was it like you know cuz I
know right now you're you you want to
get on SNL you want to be a writer on
SNL you want to be a performer on SNL
and and I know you're in the process of
trying to make that happen so but so how
was the go face process you know
it was a dream man like cuz ah I love
stand-up and I love sketch those things
just come to me like I have an antenna
and those ideas just get beamed down to
me I have a real aptitude for stand-up
and sketch and I've been able to do
stand-up just you know that's what I've
been doing but sketch to do it in a
professional kind of high production way
you you need to get tapped to do it by
by like a network or something you know
if you're not doing it on YouTube or
something so but the craziest trajectory
is I got into stand-up because I loved
SNL I just love that show growing up and
I research how do people get on it and
they either went to Groundlings Second
City UCB or they did stand-up and then I
I googled the schools and then you have
to pay money I go stand up just seems
more doable it's free you know what I
mean and my parents have weren't like
super stoked about comedy so I can't
tell them I'm going to clown school
right yeah especially cuz you were an
engineer yeah yeah yeah so I mean well
they paid for college but I could only
do that was like the lowest degree I can
do and have them still pay for it so did
stand-up and all that and wait wait wait
wait hold on one second yeah
you hear that that's the standard of
Afghan parents yeah is that the lowest
degree you can get is I'm mechanical
mechanical engineer you know so they're
like they're like disappointed when
they're talking about dude
Oh honestly like I got the degree and I
was at work I was working at Boeing so
I'm working at Boeing aerospace like
they're ashamed at dinner parties like
our son he's a mechanical engineer at
Boeing and you know or do they spit out
their drink how can you show your face
knowing this I just you said that is you
said it so casually that I would just
like to get to myself Wow yeah other
places have about education so you got
your life so manacle engineer degree
yeah yeah I mean but also just to kind
of like get a degree where I knew I
would get a job to support myself cuz I
knew I wanted to move out here to LA
while I pursued all this stuff and yeah
I did it I worked and then I was doing
some sketch just with goat-face
you know first on my own and then I
teamed up with goat-face and we were
doing we just thought that there was an
exciting time like there had never been
a sketch show or a sketch group with
four Brown dudes doing really
intelligent just funny sketch like
sometimes it's about being brown but
sometimes it's about being American just
totally normal to be able to switch hit
like that I always thought it was like a
hybrid of in living color and
Chappelle's Show and living color and
that it would be the first to have that
racial caste that racial background for
brown dudes and then the social
commentary of like a Chappelle's Show
and we were trying to sell it and stuff
but this is before Trump got elected and
just it didn't seem so obvious so he's
got a bunch of know there's like for two
years we were doing the sketch thing and
then his song gets daily show and then
also some acting stuff and just kind of
evaporated and then years later I'm
walking to the comedy store and Hassan's
profile is risen he's he's doing daily
show he does the White House
Correspondents Dinner and then he does
his own special homecoming king on net
so the white house thing and the
homecoming king really kind of
catapulted him and I'm walking in the
Comedy Store and his manager is like Oh
Comedy Central they want to do a sketch
show with with goat-face just random as
[ __ ] it just drops in your lap sometimes
you push things so hard and then you get
nowhere and and then other times things
just kind of fall out of the sky
it's weird yeah the way this business
works and it was just a one-off like
almost like a one-off like yeah it was a
1 hour one hour sketch special so it
wasn't a series is just like a but it
was cool cuz we got to do what we did on
YouTube but for like on steroids though
like really high production aristotle's
a great director some of the ideas I was
able to do were pretty high level
because we had the money from the sets
and all that and what's funny is around
that time we were about to ramp up on
production for go phase and then I got
an SNL audition just for LA so they were
seeing people in LA and I did the
audition over at i/o so so I just did
stand-up on there I think Casey Affleck
was in the crowd and Ben Affleck and
then this look and then one of the
producers as well from from SNL and I I
did what I wanted to do stand-up wise
but I didn't get it then but it was
almost a blessing cuz it allowed me to
carry through with gelt face and do that
project with my friends and kind of
finish what we started and just do it on
a large on a large scale
and so I'm very proud of it what we did
yeah should be proud of it it was great
thanks man if you youtube goat face i
think there might be some of the
sketches that they put up on youtube
finally and that's what's great about
what's great about youtube but what's
great about the sketch platform art form
is it translates great to youtube you
know like i think key & peele is
probably bigger on youtube it is when it
was on TV itself sure cuz i even myself
I find myself going in a rabbit hole of
you know key appeal sketches and out
then I'm just laughing for an hour and
I'm like oh yeah I just watched like you
know 5000 sketches or whatever it is
they caught the tail end of that
paradigm shift between TV and the
because they were a TV show and then I
remember towards the end of their show
they were no no they they would have
some clips on YouTube and at the end of
their YouTube clips they'd be like hey
guys key & peele is on there like
pleading with people to watch watch the
show because they didn't realize this is
how people consume media nowadays they
were still fighting it yeah and then
once they embraced YouTube it took off
once they realize like oh these are
they're getting the views but in a
different way it's different metrics oh
man I love that's one of my favorites I
mean it's like yeah I'm like I say what
I like about sketch on the Internet is
you could cut all the fat off of this
like a lot of shows have too much
[ __ ] like the whole Deline cuz even
in SNL you know I like SNL and I know
you're a big fan of SNL but I could do
it out to musical guests I could do
without the opening monologue I could do
without the interstitials and all that
stuff I'm just like cut to you know cut
to the church lady cut - yeah whatever
the things are I just want to see that
so I love sketch shows on the internet
on the internet cuz all the fats gone
even we were when we were making goat
face I made it a point I told the guys I
go I want no fat on this thing I want it
to be all digestible for the Internet
there's no fluff there's no I didn't
want to do like the us coming out be
like hey guys even though they did they
made us kind of do that up top because
they're high still don't like that I
just want pure uncut sketch like mr.
show was like that I just want raw a ton
of sketch but they were like oh they
want to know who you are to get a feel
for your personalities but in my mind
I'm like no one's gonna watch this [ __ ]
live it's gonna be on the internet so
you have to do that thing where you come
out and you're like yeah what's up
everybody just like this fluff that
that's like the meat and potatoes are
the sketches
yeah but but the interstitials we did
stand-up and i thought that was cool
because i wanted people to know that we
are all stand-ups which i think is
unique because I I think stand-ups don't
get a lot of love in the sketch world
you have to come from UCB you have to
come it's very cliquey very zum it's an
institution you kind of have to
like the one the only way you can kind
of come or like be taken seriously
sketch is to come through Groundlings or
UCB whereas I always felt like I'm a
stand-up who's actually like good at
sketch as well and I would get
overlooked just because I'm a stand-up
so that's why I thought it was very cool
to show like no we're for stand-ups who
are doing sketch pretty well yeah yeah
talk about like Oh what you think about
the the sub-sect of sub sex of comedy
especially looking la like I didn't even
know there was like this sketch comedy
so yeah it's a whole world whole scene I
didn't even know about it's like just
like there's a whole alternative comedy
scene and then like I would be
considered mainstream you know I'm in
the mainstream then we're the one that's
looked down upon the most right
I don't yeah but what's weird is is now
the pendulum is shifted let's say pre
corona though where it was all about
meltdown and all that stuff and then now
it's all about the store and that's
where we are so that's what's kind of
cool is to finally get some shine like
our our scene to get some shine well I
think that what's happened is that
comedy has embraced the other media
outlets forms of media outlets to help
market their comedy and their
personalities
I mean podcasting is what has made
comedy what it is right now because it's
direct-to-consumer this is no game
Kinari there's no gatekeeper there's
nothing with it or you don't
yeah this is me and then later you might
be like you know what I want to go watch
that guy do stand-up now because I liked
what he was talking about on his podcast
or or he's silly like whoever it is I
whatever kind of personality or person
you are you know to me and by the way
you don't even have to be a great
standup you know I mean you know you
know what I mean like like what we would
consider like all that that's right well
that guy's gonna be on the Mount
Rushmore of like whatever you know like
if Chapelle had a podcast it would be
like oh my oh yeah you know but you know
somebody's able to reach our fans
without the gatekeepers has been the
biggest shift and the most empowering
thing to happen to us as comedians and
even on my level like I've experienced
that because like the Netflix's aren't
there for me right
now for some reason like you're sorry
either brother yeah yeah when you
understand you're in the business long
enough you you realize it's nothing
personal people are in positions of
power they have particular tastes you
don't happen to fall in it at this point
in time maybe later you will but you
don't want to like sit on your hands
just hoping this hot girl will like you
you figure out other ways I think
earlier in my career I was waiting for
mr. Hollywood to like tap me it's your
turn for him it's your turn and then you
realize let me look good for mr.
Hollywood
hi mr. Hollywood how are you is there an
opening and then you realize that's like
a pipe dream that's not how it works and
it's just a mirage that you're waiting
for this this person doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you and I had all this I had my
special I didn't foresee so I have bits
of just me doing spots around town and I
started chopping it up and putting it on
Instagram and I said that's how I
started to grow on Instagram like people
were discovering me that way and that
was really eye-opening like oh this is
Netflix in everyone's pocket yeah and
it's and it's not region protected wine
no one's telling me I can't do a thing
that I know I can do right right
comedy's weird like like this is my
point of view by the way people watching
right now so even if team doesn't have
to even answer or respond it's just
because I'm what I was what this is what
I think's happened to comedy recently is
that stand-up comedy's not enough for
people because a lot of it's mediocre so
to be great at stand-up to really
captivate a crowd there are very few
stand-ups that actually can do that so
then what the comedy business does is
they find ways to get to let people who
are mediocre comedians shine so they do
roast battle they do like all these
different types of like comedy plus you
know do laundry on stage and let's see
who does you know that's you know they
have to have these like tricks and
gimmicks because yeah because dangle
some keys whenever outside of yeah
because the regular cuz I was watching
this show
and I was so mad when I was watching it
but then I found myself enjoying it
later but rebel Wilson is hosting this
show on Netflix and it's a bunch of
Australian comics or New Zealand
Australian comics right there like in
like not a house but there in this thing
the whole point of the show is that it's
a contest they have to try to make each
other laugh and whoever laughs in this
room they get disqualified and as a
shows coming on my girl wants to watch
it and I'm like this is ridiculous like
what you know but then as I started to
watch it I was like oh this is hilarious
like and then I thought to myself how
great do you know funny that would be if
it was like the Comedy Store guys like
you trying to make each other laugh and
these guys they're talking [ __ ] about
each other and I was like oh this is
like so great but I go okay so now I get
it so it's like you know I had to let me
like I had to like we think my feeling
about it yeah same time I'm like damn
can't stand up be enough I know we're
just such purists cuz we've dedicated
our lives to this craft that we want
good stand up to be enough and sometimes
I think we forget that especially
nowadays are so many specials out very
right right right that even though like
we can sit through them to comb through
them and see the value in all of them
just like the average person gets so
much like stand of atrophy they just
don't it's too much it's overexposure so
they need a gimmick wrapped into it yeah
I consider stand-up like these specials
now and they're not well you know we've
heard this a million times but they're
not special but their content you know
it's like you're in a vine video but
like for an hour you know they're
starting thing we talked about this
before is just I mean I want to get this
point across I think people don't think
about it is this shift with stand-up
comedy that's going on we're like
identity politics has become more
important than the actual bar being set
by the comedian or like how good the
comedy is it's more about like like yes
representation is important but
sometimes representation right now is
more value as being put into that than
how good the comedy is you know I feel
like you I feel like that's personal for
you it's personal for me they say that
is because yeah my parents from
Afghanistan
I'm proud to be Afghan I have some jokes
sometimes about it but I grew up in
Seattle and very American in my comedy
brain has very is just very regular very
normal sensibilities and I think
sometimes because I don't address being
brown a lot some of those diversity
opportunities aren't afforded to me
because I'm not being diverse in the way
they want me to be diverse yeah I'm in
the same boat with you brother because
for me it's like I'm not specific I'm
not something enough you know I'm just
white it's like what why is it funny
enough yeah but it's like you know so
even when you're like you know and I've
been on so many different types of shows
I've been on a Latino show for doing
stand-up I've been on a black show for
doing stand-up I've been on the white
shows for doing on a tiny show I just
don't tell anybody they don't know but
but I feel like some of the people want
to know they wanted to be specific they
wanted to be like well we want yeah
you're you're are you black because we'd
love you to be blacker it's really what
they're saying you know we want you to
be like you're not you know we need
you're like 6:30 and we need midnight
you know I've never heard it put like
that we need midnight we need a gremlin
like the Sun is setting but we kind of
need at night so so I understand what
you're saying like I so sometimes I just
but see I don't want to rage against
that all the time too it's like you know
because it's right now when I feel
something when I see a ton of white
celebrities especially even the comics
how they're addressing the George Floyd
and black lives matter
sometimes it's cringy to me ya know
because for me I'm like just been going
on like what we're so because you think
this is like this is the most popular
thing to do right now or you know you
feel the pressure of like now you want
to step out and be like I think what's
crazy is there had never been a video
frame so perfectly like Scorsese
couldn't have directed it better you
know what I mean in terms of just
capturing what minorities have known
for years and finally it was so black
and white and clear-cut that nobody
could like justify it anymore they
couldn't be like well the police officer
didn't know he felt threatened just all
those excuses were gone with this video
and that's why you see so many white
people and so many people out in the
streets side by side cuz like it took
that to get hit over the head with to be
like I [ __ ] get it now you know what I
mean yeah fortunate but it's crazy I my
I have a I have a big brother for Big
Brother's of America you know when I was
seven years old you know I still know
him today you know so he's like the one
of the person I know them the longest in
my life but I remember back in the day
when the Rodney King beating happened I
remember how shocked he was as a white
guy you know my Jewish guy he said I
remember him saying that to me he's like
I didn't think that that really happened
like that was his mentality was like you
hear black talk about the cops
yeah really really how long ago was that
and people were towing that line up
until George Floyd but by the way those
cops got off so like this isn't over yet
like but you know it's funny you say
that like Scorsese couldn't directed it
better that video was like as if
Scorsese was directing it as if Scorsese
was saying like it would be funny sketch
would be like to play that video this is
not funny as dark but you're playing
that video and then you hear then you
cut over and Scorsese is like now now
you really hate them you know like
you're playing it to to real or whatever
like you're too sinister dialing that
guy's face man like you know so I know
what you're saying that there was
something about this particular video
footage of seeing a man one knowing that
he's being filmed looking at people
filming him and the length of time the
length of time and figure I can't
breathe and like the several like how
many more indicators do you need like
every excuse is gone yeah yeah it was
almost like like it was almost as if
like is it you know like
you know like there's a white panel you
know and and they you know you start the
video and the white panels like yeah but
you know it was poppy resisting arrest
and like oh okay
keep going you know they say well he
probably well the thing just every
excuse has taken away yeah but he was
trying to get
oh he's handcuffed totally oh he was
being belligerent for his mom
it's like it was like that video took
away all to the point where not one
prominent white politician like to
justify it justify it you know even
Trump himself had to be like that was
terrible what's like never ceases to
amaze me though is that for as
progressive is where we're headed
towards and all that stuff I'm on the
internet every day you know you're on
everyone's on the internet every day
there's a new video every day and just
like a different type like it'll be
called Karen's calling the cops on a
black guy it'll be that or it'll be like
someone not wanting to wear their masks
and coughing on babies and stuff every
day you're like how many of you are out
there knowing that everyone has a cell
phone camera well you know the thing is
is like okay but here's the thing though
I think Will Smith said it best I don't
know I don't want to mess I don't know
what his quote was I don't wanna I'm
saying I'm like I might be butchering it
but he says yeah there's not more racism
it's just being filmed you know yes you
know so I just but for for them to you
would think that well once you know the
entire world has cell phone cameras the
racism would be a little more low-key
and undercover I say you know what what
you're talking about is optics you know
yeah like like this is what I have been
saying on my podcast for a few weeks now
is that I don't get why the governor's
mayor's police chiefs weren't going hey
guys um we get it some of you don't like
black people
right but let's not do this stuff on
film anymore you know like really like
the cameras interfacing like what you
filming me yeah go go ahead like they
get embolden like yeah it's like let's
it's almost as if you go like cuz you go
really again like you know keep going
like you got filmed again like as if
like they're shocked it's just like
these cops to get kinda like ah that
tells me this is what really bothers me
about like that George Ford video that
guy had the look of someone who thought
he was gonna get away with it cuz they
always do right no and they have in the
past or what has he gotten away with
that he goes this is gonna be fine so
that's the part that's scary so I think
there has to be a shift amongst those
type of people too because look by the
way to be a cop is not easy it's a
dangerous job you have to have a certain
level of like loyalty to justice because
the cops during the riots they can
easily be liked by like the cops could
just be like imagine if the cops would
have been like okay well alright good
luck burn the city down it's like the
riders the rioters and people protesting
like that they need the cops there or
it's meaningless true but I think we've
seen that there's just this
institutionalized cultural problem
within the force and we saw it when the
protests were happening like again how
many of these videos are you seeing like
teargas canisters to the face and just
you're like yeah this is the time you
must be on your best behavior and you
can't do it for a week okay but devil's
advocate at the same time though if
you're protesting
that these people are not acting
properly and then you want to be mad
during the protest that they're not
acting properly like and by the way
they're outnumbered like the one they're
out there in the streets like and the
people are throwing things and they're
doing this yes and now we're it's like
that yeah British make these cops to be
like hey everybody you know I don't want
to put my hands on you know at that
point I had to I mean I they're human
beings also I agree when it gets heated
and riot and there's bricks and stuff
they
defend themselves but when like the guy
in Buffalo kind of into his head cracks
open and like you don't need to do that
and then when they all sit like do a
rudi like if he's off the force we are
like that's the hill you're dying on I
know and the thing she was like that's
what I say about like
it's a dangerous job you knew that going
in and you you have to be better then
that's part of the job is like you have
to be better than us
yes that's the job I hate the excuse of
light what George Floyd was a criminal
right or or any person that you do you I
go so yeah like name-calling is not like
it's not fun but my point my point is
like yeah they're a criminal okay but
you're not the judge jury and
executioner you're supposed to enforce
the law enforced justice and live up to
that that's your [ __ ] job I think
sometimes they forget they're in a
uniform so if a guy's saying like [ __ ]
you to a cop or whatever like yeah it
sucks to be called that
and you probably shouldn't be doing that
but it's not illegal and you you kind of
have to be able to just you know put up
with like window when the Kukla what's
to go on a March you know yeah you know
I know that can't be exactly it's always
so it's always so bizarre like you know
when you when you think about like we
put ourselves in certain situations and
it's like this is analogous to it but
it's like in a comedy club setting we
make people buy alcohol mm-hmm and then
we also ask them to drive at minimum two
drinks we say you need to get two things
of alcohol that's just the minimum but
you can be quiet and behave yourself
like it's almost ridiculous but people
can but statistically when you introduce
a certain amount of alcohol
and to people they forget the rules and
just like their boisterous personality
comes out and sometimes it's too much
for a live show and they just can't
handle it well that's what I'm saying
it's the same thing about like you know
but I still feel that there's a certain
type of personality of person that
becomes a cop or a person that game day
they gotta be a rough rider you know I
had this thought I go why do people
become cops it's not to do paperwork
they watch bad boys or
watch and it's always like like it's
like wanting to be a porn star and you
never get to [ __ ] chicks you know like
they want to be like what the [ __ ] say
that to my face
imagine you the porn star and all you're
doing is you know you go in and they
have you filing and you're like yeah
yeah yeah they go when do I [ __ ] chicks
and go that's only in the movies traffic
tickets see that's what I mean about you
and your brain like you you think yeah
you think in sketch for my you have an
idea and I do this too and that's why I
like talking to you when we start
talking about ideas because to me it's
already formed like I already see like
how we're gonna film it like I really
like you're like oh okay oh we can get
really get Ian Edwards and this person
and then we'll do it like this and it's
like and I love it it's so excited like
once we're talking or something about a
situation and then I see the sketch just
like I get so giddy man and I just want
to like I just want to share it and
paint the world and kind of like do it
with whoever I'm talking to to you know
that me I'm like a little older than you
so I go back to the time when we
actually did sketch shows like there was
no filming it was just a sketch show I
was in a shitty sketch group you know
they still do it you mean like UCB stuff
or no but no no you see being all that
kind of stuff I would say that that's a
like it's a step above amateur okay you
know it's still amateur but it's like
they if they got a practice space it's
being led see back in the day it was
just a group of friends got together and
you were gonna do sketches you know and
it's like you didn't have a leader you
would have to rent like I remember
renting a [ __ ] theater in Hollywood
and we would put on sketch shows and it
was not you didn't but you'd invite
people down and yeah yeah you invited
people to come watch them and those days
are I know people are still doing them
but when they do them I think it's more
a professional thing as they set up but
we used to just do it because it was the
only way to like get that get that
energy out so you had your dumb sketch
group and you would do these like crazy
sketches and you you know and you'd put
on shows in front of like 13 people and
you know I still remember my sketch
group was called the suckling pigs
oh yeah I don't even remember
everybody's like oh I remember you guys
I don't even remember everybody's name
that was in the group that's how long
ago it was
you know only other guy remembers Jim
Bruce Jim's the only guy I remember but
like everyone else Jen Bruce and I
remember one of the guys saying to me
like wit this is why I needed to leave
the group because I was young I was in
my 20s you know and we were doing this
these terrible sketches you know cuz
some of them were just bad you know and
but one of the guys was like guys we all
we're all Chuck none of us are ever
gonna be on TV
and he said that and that's when I was
like I need to get away from you oh
that's toxic man yeah yeah yeah I said I
don't want that type of energy around me
because I am going to be on TV I am
going to make it that's how I thought
about it so that's why I'm kind of
protective like when I was coming up
protective of my dream I wouldn't tell
like I never told anyone at Boeing that
I did stand-up even when I was going to
college studying engineering I didn't
tell anybody that I was doing stand-up
as well yeah because it was very much my
thing and I had a personal relationship
with it and I know it seems naive to a
lot of people but they can't see it like
I can see it you know what I mean
yeah and I don't even if they're like oh
that's great I want to come see you
sometime it's like watching a toddler
jump off a diving board like that's the
energy of it yeah and I don't need that
I know the perception and I don't want
to have to deal with it so that's why I
just kept it to myself how does your
mechanical engineering side of your
brain how does it how does it mesh with
your creative side for the stand-up or
do they mesh at all or they completely
separate parts of your brain
I think they complement each other
really well and I think I always had an
artistic edge growing up the engineering
came later engineering I was like 18 and
I had to go to college right I was for
your post that was for my parents and I
was able to do it and yeah you have to
be good at school or you know they get
mad at you and stuff so but I would use
to dance and stuff when I was a kid I
always had a performer element to me
as a young child but engineering it just
it teaches you time management structure
it just gives you very crystalline ways
of thinking and I think that structure
coupled with the magic of state like
ideas comedy and and like artistry
it gave structure to that so I'll think
of an idea and I know
okay this bit goes here this bit goes
here like this like an engineering
formula or like a right high end of or
you cut it's like a scaffolding you're
building it like when I think about
stand-up I think of or just comedy in
general stand-up ideas are um they're
like LEGO pieces to me so I'll think of
a funny concept or a funny idea and it's
a red Lego piece and then I it's just
floating around I'm living my life and
then maybe next week I think of another
idea and that's also a red leg Lego
piece and I go back that kind of fits
and then once I have enough red LEGO
pieces that's a bit
you know what I mean yes I do and then I
think of another bit or something and
I'll go that's a blue Lego piece and
then you just kind of figure out how to
then you're putting together a set list
yeah that's interesting you know
something that you mentioned just now
two of I want the people to understand
too is that you're actually a fantastic
dancer I'm okay like I'm kind of
flattered they're great dancer yes I
always said I say for a stand-up
comedian I'm a pretty good dancer by
dancer standards
I don't know cooking oh yeah am i
singing I feel that way about my singing
am i cooking for a comic but I do like
sometimes I'll get a DM from like a
legit dancer and they'll be like no you
have like rhythm you have like
sophisticated rhythm and I go oh that
feels good cuz like they're a pro yeah
that way when I was when I was around
these like professional like real like
dramatic actors on I'm dying up here you
know and like you know they pull me
aside and be like you know you believe
you talk to agents about this because
you got it you there's something about
your leg and I was like really touched
by that you know yeah ELISA leo this
like oscar-winning actress is like
pulling me aside and like giving me tips
like like you know I remember preparing
a scene with her and just the things she
was telling me you know to me like just
the intensity of her saying like you
know you know I do it this way and like
tap into this and like just the way they
would discuss the scene and like and
I'll go oh [ __ ] okay this is how you're
getting to certain emotions and feelings
and like ya know cuz they're they're
looking at it that way but I realized I
understood it because I do that with my
stand-up you know with my stand-up like
I all my standup there's an emotional
thing and if I don't have that emotion
when I'm performing it it doesn't come
across the same way or it comes across
different each time I do it because
sometimes I'm in a move where I'm like a
little bit mellow and the same joke I'll
do when I'm doing a little bit mellow it
actually hits differently then if I had
this edge of like this is really taking
me off or online you know so I realized
that that
same thing is how acting works that's
exactly how acting works it's like
here's the words but what am I feeling
right now and how do I translate that
with with this environment and and then
and with this scene partner and inlet it
just made me realize I was like oh wow
okay I really did enjoy doing dramatic
acting yeah I mean that's so great to be
pulled in that world and kind of on on
the job training with someone like that
you know that's exactly what it was
totally on-the-job training so but yeah
but back to you though it's like you
know I can tell though when you're
dancing that there's a part of you that
was like you wish you were a
professional dancer like there's a part
of you that there's a part of you that
wishes it would like like you're in a
music video with Chris Brown you know
like you're one of the guys in the back
you know like you know it's like doing
all your moves and stuff I feel like
this [ __ ] thinks he's a backup
dancer for [ __ ] Paula Abdul right now
I'll give you a few thoughts like okay
so like dancing was the first thing I
ever did like I was a little kid I was
like a baby and I would dance I would
dance like Michael Jackson and that was
just my way to express myself so dancing
is very it's like when you smell
something and you're transported to a
certain place or whatever dancing is
like my first thing it's almost very
primal for me I don't think about
anything I'm like I'm a very heady guy
I'm overly analytical I think about
things too much when I dance it's like
there's not a care in the world it's
just like I feel the music so much and
it's great it's really cool it's almost
like meditating where I'm not worrying
about [ __ ] and it's just about dancing
and I'm kind of transported to a
different world and it's almost like a
different person you know so there's
that element of it that's why I love I
love dance and then I don't know if I
want to be the Chris Brown guy but I
would have these Hollywood fantasies I
would I would I always wanted to do this
thing where I wanted to be a backup
dancer for like Christina Aguilera one
time just for like one show cuz it makes
no sense that's that's what I read now
but I don't make a career out of it like
I wanted to be an established comedian
right just and and and then and then
just like wait is that Fahim up there
just feel like one one tour you know
what I mean like
like they're in Barcelona and I'm up
there just for one sec are made a music
video for like a split second that was
my dream and then also remember early on
in my twenties I told my people I was
like get me in a step-up movie I want to
be in a step-up movie in the worst way
it was funny about that I wanted to be
on Glee just as bad because I was I
wanted to be the coach or the teacher on
Glee and I wanted to be like Wacka
singsong so I was like Katy Perry
especially if you have the skill set
like all you can do is ask but I just I
wanted to be in a step-up movie in the
worst way and so whatever those things
didn't work out but I I kind of have had
like fractions of that or shades of that
like I was um you were great on the on
the what's your college show what's the
show on a funny dance show funny dance
show I gotta tell you I know you you
loved every second of that of course
I'll tell you how much I loved it well
here was my thought process okay so if
people who don't know there's a show on
E from Justine and in Heidi this so our
friends they're comics as well so they
take comedians to comedians vs. to
comedians and it you dance you kind of
it's supposed to be like funny but then
also kind of good it depends on how good
you are as a dancer one of those things
stand-ups not enough I go this makes
sense no everything else is [ __ ] but
this show is awesome so they gave us
choreographers they gave us a set it was
like really well produced it was back in
gingers backup dancers and they trained
us for they gave us a routine and they
trained us for like three days like
we're in a dance studio and everything
and most other people would like go home
but I stayed after like cuz heroes my
thought I go I'm kind of good at dancing
I'm pretty good so I can really capital
I could really juice this thing because
when else am I going to be able to learn
from these choreographers when else am I
going to have these
when else am I gonna have these backup
dancers taking wider itis yeah why not
just put a little extra time and effort
especially if I can dance and really do
a great show if I couldn't dance then
it'd be like yeah whatever ha ha but
like I was like let's do this right and
I think it showed when we finally filmed
it yeah it was great man
it was great thanks and then side know
also I I'm a fortnight dance so if
anyone plays fortnight one of the emotes
is me dancing somehow like they found
because I was giddy
yeah they paid me because people were
like condo right because I heard they
were like they used to Jack moves and
stuff like that and so whenever I told
people I posted it on my Instagram
because I have a side by side of the
dance and what they ended up using and
people like oh they [ __ ] you I'm like no
no they they paid me they made a deal um
but it was random as [ __ ] cuz you know
sometimes I dance in my place yeah so
back when I was living in Korea because
you would date you did a dance on
Instagram and I saw and I was like and I
tried to copy I did it I did a dance in
front of my door it was one of the posts
that people love the most
it was dude it's crazy that's what I've
noticed too I'll post my standup I'll
post some sketches and then sometimes
I'll just do like a dumb dancing thing
and it gets way more comment there's
just something it transcends logic it's
like it's such a heart game cuz you know
you learned stand-up actually isn't
enough I guess we got to stop doing this
thing you know maybe a covetous my
gaming videos I put I'll put a gaming
video up now and get some more views on
my Instagram that even like this you
know so I might get it people want to be
you know we don't know what clicks with
people it just does yeah but I just
think that's such a cool credit to have
like I'm a stand-up comedian why do I
have a fortnight dance but it's my
favorite credit yeah yeah random well
listen dude I think you're fantastic I
hope you do get on SNL I hope that in
hey maybe the goat face still comes back
you never know maybe you know the doors
not sure you'll be
like Denny's or something and somebody
goes three seasons ago face you you
never know so but I'm sure I'm sure
there's there's big things ahead I mean
you did that one you know sometimes a
lot of people they have the first crack
it's not the one that makes it big you
know you're a second third thing or
whatever it might be what I'm sure there
is gonna be a thing like that
everything is stepping stones to the
next thing and we're in the game and
that's kind of all that matters
yes it is well this has been for him I
appreciate you being on I have all your
information below and yeah click here
here here podcast here sketches here
stand-up special here hopefully the main
point of time I'm gonna like try to grab
you its clips put it up yeah just try to
put it on the screen if I have time but
like actually real quick take time
that's the new one I know I don't even
get it that should be right in your
wheelhouse
tick tock bus I guess I'm I have some
stuff that have done pretty well on
there but I can't figure I feel like
Chris Hanson is gonna pop onto my phone
and be like what are you doing here I
know I feel too old for Tic Tacs yeah I
think it's like that's what that's the
one app that I was like oh yeah
I'll see a four you page is just like
some like some kid like this and it has
like five million views what video ends
like oh that was it's like the comments
and then and then I do it and it's just
like like two views I don't know how it
goes viral man I don't know but we'll
figure it out maybe this goes viral so
make just do it let's do a dance and
then we'll go viral man I know yeah it's
to promote it that's what we'll do but
anyways thanks for coming on or sister
for he Manoir and please could continue
to subscribe share I appreciate you guys
watching if you want to watch me game
I'm on Eric Griffin gaming every single
day long twitch and again this has been
Fahim and thank you for watching and I
will see you next week guys thanks a lot
man hi man see you soon hopefully did